hello hi I'll guide you through this
game thank you thank you for wasting
your time playing this that's pretty
much what I do with every game that I
play anyway there's a zombie apocalypse
oh and everyone died sounds like one of
my stories and the main reason of this
is everyone was taking selfies with Dom
zombies instead of running away and
trying to survive hey I can dig it
better than some movies I've seen but
you were too poor to have a snart
smartphone and too dumb to say
smartphone properly so you're alive
alright but the earth is filled with
zombies so it's not safe for you to be
here I have an idea let's go to the moon
so all you have to do is build a rocket
get all the things you need to survive
and fly to the moon oh oh okay and I'm
gonna give you the best flashlight ever
SCT I don't know what that stands for oh
now I do oh okay
Oh only a true gentleman can play this
game where is my fedora oh god they put
it on my head I have to collect fix it
to collect things from this oh god no oh
God
why are you bang okay oh oh no no no oh
no okay ah Wow disco balls really
blaring OH
oh my goodness Oh
was just a Christmas special or
something oh wait a minute there oh hey
oh geez you looks good these armies oh
hey
yeah okay then ma'am but no I what are
you doing
hello oh yeah the genes-- sneak up on me
but they'll never get me as I go into
this potty house yeah now that I got my
Christmas tree right late and my
unnecessary top hat and monocle in
mustache I wish you as pink can sue and
mod this game to make it pink wow this
looks like the exact layout Oh TV of
course I'll need this for my trip to the
moon
good thing I'm poor so I'll steal it I
guess that did that sounded worse than I
wanted it to I have nothing to say about
socioeconomic status I'm just trying to
play a game and get to the moon the
gender [ __ ] you BAM boom boom where did
you all come from well I miss I probably
don't deserve to serve a Hello could you
stop hugging me from behind I have
places to go and people to see and also
there's a penguin in a barrel looking at
me and waving I am so confused okay
let's go to the moon you know I'm trying
to come up with things to say you know
like intelligent commentary to make
about this game but I mean I think it
pretty much speaks for itself it's
absolutely amazing astonishing really
how well-crafted is and now well put
together all the elements they fit and
jelly oh damn these guys like here out
of nowhere oh oh bullet okay yeah I got
fuel I'm supposing Oh II well there's
gonna be a last stand type situation
okay never mind that I guess I'm totally
fine well good Fermi then hello okay
fuel metal for the rocket find the
engine Oh hon didn't even look up oh hey
how's it going gentlemen okay so I need
to find the engine and then I need I
don't know I don't know man I'm just
trying to get by day by day
also weird I was just a nice poor man
living on the streets but I was you know
kind of happy I didn't have a lot of
responsibilities which was nice I guess
you know I would have like you know a
place to live that would have been nice
I guess I'll have the whole moon to
myself that'll be cool I don't know I
seem to have some weird skin condition
where all my body parts seem like
they're made of clay in addition to my
gun that's not too much of a problem I
try not to let that bother me I try to
go by my day by day I try to do nice
things for other people even though
other people are now zombies and I have
to kill them and I smell very nice no
bees Oh God we have not the bees
ah okay nevermind then I guess we're
fine okay I'm gonna go get some things I
hope I don't have to shoo more zombo's
oh look more zombo's bang that BAM boom
okay cool
an engine that was a lawnmower you
weren't there before okay alright this
is going swimmingly I'm so happy for me
and all my endeavors wanna go to the
moon maybe this is just some fevered
drug trip like I was just playing a game
where I was in a hospital looking for
drugs so maybe this is just a
continuation of that and this is the
logical next step I'm seeing penguins
and barrels shooting random zombie
people flying in the moon but as a
gentleman also I guess I haven't really
questioned the Christmas tree but it is
given me oh just put all this metal in
my pocket okay
just about as logical as anything else
I've ever done I guess I'll go this way
probably not the correct path but I
don't really have any of the lights to
guide me by and I don't even see the
moon anymore boy this is ideal place to
get ambushed by a zombie
oh look actually I think I might be
going the right way except I see zombies
over there well time to murder can I
spot a head shot from all this way oh
look at you you're dead
bang I'm amazing oh hey another one
another one another one another one
another one
oh hey / Nick oh I didn't know that I
needed bananas but I guess no one really
knows when they need bananas it just
kind of happened upon it in their life
don't read too much into that
oh I am flying to the moon end I am
going into space and got a pocket full
of metal and a engine that's a lawn mow
earth and bananas oh oh wait oh it's hot
I okay uh yeah fine by me I guess I got
everything I need oh okay we're done
then my bananas what happened oh man I
forgot the joy of playing random indie
games oh wow I love that Vout ten out of
ten
god damn that was amazing oh so cool uh
I've set him enough already so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what other crazy weird random indie
games you'd like me to play in the
future so thanks again everybody and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
I've ever seen
sit down little wall